Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of
my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God, and in the same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings want or desires, and may you,
my beloved divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to
your most holy will so intimately that I may never swerve from carrying out what I know to be your
good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels
and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the holy
spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in
these writings and prayers. Amen. So good evening everyone, and let us begin with August the 27th,
1926. Here Jesus speaks about the title he wants to give to this work, and he also speaks about the
person who must take responsibility for carrying this out, and that's the part that applies to us.
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, "My beloved Jesus made me see the reverend father who
must occupy himself with the printing of the writings on his adorable will, and Jesus placing
himself near the priest, said to him, 'My son, the title you will give to the book that you will
print about my will is this, the kingdom of my divine will in the midst of creatures, the book of
heaven, the call of the creature to the order, the place, and the purpose for which it was created by
God.' See, I want the title also to correspond to the great work of my will. I want the soul,
instead of seeing creature, we're all souls to God. I want the soul to understand this particular
soul is the priest in question, that his place assigned to him by God is in my will. Now that applies
to every single one of us, and until he enters into it he will be without a place, he will be without
order, and he will be without purpose in life. That applies to the whole human race, and therefore
you see the chaos that's in the earth today. If he doesn't enter into it, he will be an intruder
in the creation with no rights at all, and therefore he will go wandering without peace and without
inheritance. Now I want to stop with the wandering there, it's a very important word. Wandering means
you have no address, you have nowhere to lay your head, and I want to bring you back to the book of
Genesis chapter 4 verse 12, where because of killing his brother, Cain was sent wandering around the
earth. In other words, he was an intruder, as you are reading here. But I also want you to see
that at the time of Christ, when they chosen people absolutely rejected their Messiah and chose the
secular arm, we have no king except Caesar, that the result of that was that the entire nation became
the wandering Jews, and that was so for 1948 years. It's a very serious matter not to get our
inheritance that's given to us in the kingdom of God. Now if you go to Matthew 19, 29, and Matthew 25,
34, we are to take the inheritance that's actually given to us, it's given to us for free. It's like
parents passing on an inheritance to their children. It's free, it's because of your relationship with
the parent that you actually receive it. And so if we refuse this inheritance, it is a deliberate
insult to the giver. And Jesus says to him, "You must come and take your inheritance and live in
your house." Now your house is actually not your address on earth, your house is in the divine will
in the bosom of the most holy Trinity. That's where we are to live. And we're to live there now,
not just wait until we die. Why would you want to live in a foreign house? Why would you want to
occupy a land that's not yours? And because it's not yours, you will live unhappy, you will be a servant
and the laughingstock of all creation things. Now all creation things, as we know, are in the divine
will. They cannot move from the divine will because they've no free will. And so they will be totally
aware of those who are not into the divine will. So if you go back to Genesis chapter three,
well, first of all, Genesis chapter two, where the whole of creation was in communion with Adam and
Eve. And Genesis chapter three, when Adam and Eve moved out of the divine will, all the creatures
moved away from Adam and Eve. And even the earth refused to cooperate when they wanted to get
something out of the earth. They were told that will produce brambles and briars for you. And so
human beings began to call the animals wild animals because they were living in their natural state
and the ones who were wild and not living in their natural state, the human race itself.
So all things created by me because they remain in their place and in order and in perfect harmony
with all the fullness of their goods assigned to them by God, you alone want to be unhappy,
but it's a voluntary unhappiness. That is the difference. It's something we choose. We choose
to reject God. We choose to go down the root of our own will. Therefore come to your place,
it is there. And I call you and I await you. Now as you know, the Lord has waited two thousand years
for all the use to come, even though this is addressed to one individual. Therefore he or she,
so you can see replies to everybody who will offer to make my will known will be my spokesperson.
Now the person who's offering to make the divine will known should be each one of us. Now if you
put two Corinthians 5 20 beside that, the same Paul says that we are ambassadors for Christ.
And here you have God telling us that we will be ambassadors for the divine will. And I will
entrust to them that's the people who will make this known to others, the secrets of the kingdom.
So all of you who are teachers and all of you who are willing to spread this knowledge to others,
then the Lord will teach you the secrets of the kingdom as you go along. All you got to do is ask.
So after this then, Louisa said that Jesus showed her the whole of creation, how all creation things
remain in their place wanted by God and therefore in perfect order and in perfect harmony among
themselves. Okay, so we're going to be talking about God's order here. This is very important.
And because they remain in their place, the supreme will maintain their existence. Now notice that if
we remain in the divine will that the supreme will will also maintain our existence. Everything
will be fresh and beautiful and ever new as he does all the time in creation. And order brings
communal happiness. That's a very important statement. Disorder in the home among the human
beings who live there creates hell in the home. Order and love brings community and unity. Okay,
so order brings communal happiness and it also brings universal strength to all. This is extremely
important. The power of a nation is not in its weapons. The power of a nation is the moral
strengths of its people. And if the people have moral strengths, they'll conquer anything. If
people do not have moral strengths, they can conquer nothing because they haven't even conquered
themselves. Okay, so I want to give you an example. The way God gave order to his chosen people at
Sinai, he gave them 10 commandments. We call them commandments, but they Jewish people correctly
call them 10 words. And in these 10 words, four of them applied to the relationship with God,
and six applied to the relationship with each other. And if they kept this order, then their
relationship with heaven was going to be right and their relationship with earth was going to be
right as well. So let me give you an example. If all of us were living in the same area, and if I
kept the 10 commandments, then you can keep your faith. That's your first four commandments,
your relationship with God. You can keep your property, your wife, your husband, your reputation,
and everything to do with you, if I simply obey the commandments of God. So if all of us do that,
we literally allow human creatures who are not perfect and never will be perfect,
we allow them to live in peace and happiness. And so it's only God's order that can actually
accomplish that. And the more God's order comes into our own souls, our own minds, our own hearts,
the more we also grow in moral and spiritual strengths. And the more God can actually work
in us and through us, if that order is there. Now, if the divine order is coming into me and
putting everything in me in its right place, then it must go out to the relationships with the people
I'm actually living with. Otherwise, there will be terrible distress between the people who are
living in the same house as you, because they would be living, there would be disorder and order
trying to make some kind of a connection. It won't work. So the order has to come into the individual
and out through the relationships from that individual. But the stronger the person in the
divine will is the more powerful will be the transforming effect on the people all around you.
That's actually quite important. So Jesus says then what enchantment to see the order and the
harmony of all creation. In other words, it's absolutely beautiful to look at. As we know,
looking out at the beauty of creation, and Jesus resuming his teaching said, "My daughter,
how beautiful our works. They are our honor and our perennial glory. Perennial, it'll never stop."
All of them remain in their place, and each created thing fulfills its office perfectly.
Now, watch this. Man alone is our dishonor in our creative work, because by withdrawing from
our will, he walks upside down. It's very, very interesting what he's going to say now.
And you'll understand society out there much better than you did before. He's walking upside
down. With his head down to the earth, in other words, the head should be connected with heaven,
and the feet connected with earth. And it's exactly the opposite. If the head is connected with the
earth, then it means the intellect, memory, and will are all out of order. And if they're out of
order, then the human person and the society that's living like that is completely disordered.
So he calls it walking with your head, with your feet up in the air. So with his head down to the
earth, and his feet up in the air, what disorder he said, it's disgusting to see them. By walking
with his head upside down, he crawls on the earth. That means the intellect, memory, and will are all
looking to the wrong place. He becomes all upset. That's the disorder. He transforms himself into
something very ugly is what he's trying to say, because normally the word transforms is used in
terms of us being transformed into light. And I think the word they should have used is he deforms
himself. So that's why I said he transforms himself into something very ugly. He deforms himself,
becomes very ugly. His sight lacks the necessary span to be able to see. He cannot move around in
space in order to know things nor defend himself of his enemy is behind his shoulders, because the
shoulders are in the wrong place. And he cannot go too far, because poor one, he has to drag himself
with the head instead of walking, because the office of walking belongs to the feet. While the
office of the head is to dominate, in other words, you should be governed by your intellect, memory,
and will, not by the mud of the earth. And unfortunately, people who are feeding on television and the
mass media have their heads on the earth, unfortunately. And most of the stuff coming through it is ugly.
So doing his own will is the true and perfect tumble of man, how to live upside down. And is
the true disorder of the human family. So this is why I care so much that my will be known. In other
words, we all have the obligation to try and tell somebody about it, so that the human being may
return to his place. He may no longer be dragging himself with his head upside down,
but walking on his feet, no longer forming my dishonor and his, but my honor and his.
Look yourself. Do creatures not look ugly in seeing them with their heads on the ground? Don't you
feel sorry for them to see them so disordered? So he shows her a picture in the next tiny paragraph,
and yes, it's absolutely off. So let's go on to August the 29th, 1926. And here he's going to tell
us something extremely important, and it's the exact opposite of what we've just looked at.
If human beings don't have God's order, then you can't do anything with it. But if you come into
God's order, he's going to show us something that is beyond our wildest dreams. My poor mind,
Louisa said, is always returning to the supreme center of the eternal will. And if sometimes I
think about something else, Jesus himself with a message of his calls my attention to crossing the
unending sea of his most holy will. So since I was thinking about something else, my sweet Jesus
was jealous. Now Exodus 34 or 14, God is very jealous of anyone who will give themselves to him
because he needs that person in order to be able to reach everybody else. God is not jealous in the
way that human beings are jealous. Their jealousy is a negative thing. His jealousy is that out of
the whole nearly 8 billion that's on the planet. He has very, very few who are prepared to actually
let him work with them at this level. And so he wouldn't want you shifting from that at all.
Okay, so let's exit us 34 or 14. There are other examples as well, but I'll just give you one.
So he was jealous. He'd class me to himself and he said, my daughter, I want you always in my will.
This is the thing that is extremely important. He does not want us to shift out at all because
in the divine will is the nature of good. Now if you don't look up some of these words in
a dictionary, you're going to be in trouble. You mean by the nature of good? I've gone to the
dictionary looking for the meaning of this word so that I could somehow explain the depth of what
he's trying to say. When he says he's going to offer us the nature of good, he's saying the
fundamental qualities of good. You'll remember that in Mark 10, 18, Jesus said nobody is good except
God alone. So God alone actually holds the nature of good. The fundamental qualities of good,
the essential characteristics of what we call good. And Jesus himself said nobody is good
except God alone. So if he's offering us that in the divine will, it is just an unbelievable gift.
So in the divine will, you will find the nature or the fundamental qualities or the essential
characteristics of what is called good. Only when a good never ends and has no beginning
and no ending, can it be called true good? In other words, the only real good is eternal.
It has to be eternal. That's why Jesus said only God has this characteristic. But if we're entering
into this extraordinary relationship with the most blessed trinity in the divine will,
he wants us to experience this. And so our journey into the divine will means that we would be
transformed more and more and more into good. That's the transformation that needs to take place.
So when a good has a beginning and an end, it's always full of bitterness, fear and anxiety and
also disillusioned because you're going to lose it. All this renders good itself unhappy and many
times one passes easily from the good of riches to miseries. Let me say that in the language we use,
we go from riches or riches to rags. In other words, a person can lose a fortune overnight.
You can go from fortune to misfortune from health to sickness because all the goods that have a
beginning are unstable, fleeting, short lived and end up in nothing. So we see people all over the
world in the terrible fires and floods and earthquakes losing literally everything and many of them
losing their lives as well, literally in seconds. So if it's short lived and fleeting, it ends up
with nothing, absolutely nothing. Okay, so let's see what lasts forever. It is my supreme will that
possesses the nature of true good, because God alone is good, because it has no beginning and no
ending. And therefore, it's good is always the same, always full, always stable. You see, he's immutable,
so it does change, not subject to change. And this is why all that the soul makes enter into the
supreme will all of her acts form in it, acquire the nature of true good. That is absolutely unbelievable,
he alone can do it. This is why all that the soul makes enter into the supreme will all of her acts
formed in it, they acquire the nature of true good, because they are in a stable immovable will,
which contains eternal and immeasurable goods. So your love, your prayer, your thanksgivings and
everything you do, take their place in an eternal beginning that never ends. The other way we say
that is in the singularity of the one act of God, that singularity that one point which contains
everything. And it's outside of time. And so our acts entering into that, they go into the
timelessness of God, which is really fantastic. So your love, your prayer, your thanksgivings and
everything you can do, take their place in an eternal beginning that never ends and therefore
acquire the fullness of the nature of good. So your prayer acquires its full value and complete
fruit. Only Jesus could tell you that. So please appreciate prayer in the divine will,
maybe more than you have. So your prayer acquires full value and complete fruit in such a way that
you yourself will not be able to understand where the fruits and the goods of your prayer will
extend, because he alone knows what he's going to do with these acts in the divine will.
It will go around through eternity, it will give itself to all and at the same time it will remain
always full of its effects. Now all acts in the divine will are eternal acts, they are universal.
So if I want my prayers in the divine will to be for Mary or Joe only, I don't understand divine will.
All the prayers are universal and they're also eternal. Your love acquires the nature of true
love. Now only God contains the nature of true love. That's 1 Corinthians 13, 13. In the end
there's faith, hope and love and the greatest of these is love and 1 Corinthians 14, 1. You must
want love more than anything else, but you have 1 John 4, 7. God himself is love, that is nature.
So if we're allowed to acquire the nature of true love, we are acquiring the possession of God.
That's actually what we're doing. And therefore a way in which you can test your growth and development
in the divine will is to just look at how much, if you look it's easier to look back
than any other way to see how much I have changed am I a different person than I was?
Like Ebenezer Scrooge we can say I'm not the man I was. I am a completely different person
because of what has happened to me. So your love acquires the nature of true love
so that unshakable love, notice unshakable no event is going to change it. No reaction of any
human being to you for any reason whatsoever political, social, family or otherwise is going
to change your love. But you've entered into a divine love and so the love that's coming through
you to them is coming from him. So your love acquires the nature of true love. It's unshakable
love that never fails, that never ends, that loves all, see the universality of it. So it has to be
love without borders. If we say you know certain people are not included then it's not this love.
It loves all. It gives itself to all and remains always with the fullness of good of the nature of
true love. In other words he keeps saying that when you operate in the divine will you can give
and give and give but you actually don't lose anything. So to everything that enters into my will
the creative strength of my will communicates its own nature that is with all of the divine qualities
and it converts it into its own acts. So it converts it into divine acts because the divine
will does not tolerate having within itself acts dissimilar to its own. There's your Hebrews 12,
14 again nothing unholy or unworthy or incomplete or anything like that can enter into the presence
of God only something that is divine and holy. So it won't tolerate something that's dissimilar
to its own. Therefore it can be said that the acts of the soul done in my will enter the inscrutable
ways of God. Now enter the inscrutable ways of God an extremely important statement. Romans 11,
30 to 36, God's ways are completely inscrutable to us. You also have Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 10 that
my ways are not your ways. My ways are is different from your ways as the heavens are from the earth.
Okay, nor can anyone know all of their innumerable effects. It's not actually possible. The same
poll admits that I cannot see, ear cannot hear, the heart cannot understand, but God has revealed
to us that which has no beginning and no end renders itself incomprehensible to the created mind
because the created mind has a beginning and an ending and it's utterly limited. Because since
the power of an act has no beginning it's missing in them all the divine things and everything that
enters my will render themselves impenetrable and inscrutable. That's why if you don't understand
some of this stuff it has nothing to do with your intelligence. It's to do with the fact that you
didn't ask the Lord to actually open up this particular part of the text to you. He has to reveal it
and he will reveal it by infused knowledge. See then the great good of operating in my will
to put a high place it raises the soul how she's given back the nature of good. I mean this is
incredible. Just as she was delivered from the womb of her creator on the other hand anything
that can be done outside of my will even if it is good cannot be called true good because it has
a beginning and an ending. First of all because the divine nourishment and its light are missing
and these acts are dissimilar from my acts taking away from the soul the likeness of the divine image.
Now the divine image was given in Genesis 1 27 and Genesis 2 7 you also have Romans 8 29
and so acts done in the human will only take away from that image. Once my will is removed the best
part is removed the greatest value of the human works therefore those are works emptied of substance
life and value in other words a waste of time. They are like plants without fruit food without
substance statues without life works without retribution which tired the limbs of the strongest.
Oh how great is the difference between operating in my will and operating without it. So I want to
give you one Corinthians chapter two where Paul describes the massive difference between the spiritual
and the unspiritual people. Therefore be attentive and do not give me this sorrow of making me see
even one act in you which does not give of my likeness. Now he's speaking specifically to
Louisa and insofar as we have given ourselves fully to the Lord it will apply to us. So in the next
paragraph how do you give Jesus rest? If you go to the seventh hour of the Passion the third hour
in Gethsemane you'll find that when Jesus wants either comfort or rest he's actually looking for
souls that's the only way you can give him that rest. So after this Jesus disappeared and he came
back a little later as though restless because of the offenses he had received taking refuge in me
he wanted to take rest and I said to him my love I've many things to tell you many things to
establish between you and me I must ask you that your will be known and that its kingdom have its
full triumph. If you rest I can't tell you anything I must be silent to let you rest but of course
she has said all the things he wanted her to say and Jesus interrupting me with unspeakable tenderness
bless me very tightly to himself he's very good at the hugs you know and kissing me told me my
daughter how beautiful on your lips is the prayer for the triumph of the Kingdom of the Supreme Will
so there's our encouragement it is the echo of my own prayer of my own size and of all my works.
Now I want to see what you wrote he changes the subject completely so he came to rest in her
she said all the right things and then he's fine so we just need to know how to respond to him when
we see him suffering and you get all the instruction you want in the hours of the passion of how to
respond. So Jesus changes the subject and he said I want to see what you wrote about the title given
to the writings about my will and as he was saying this he took the book in his hands and he seemed
to be reading what is written on August the 27th what she's just read as he was reading he remained
pensive as though placing himself in profound contemplation in such a way that I didn't dare
to tell him anything I could only hear that his heart was beating very very strongly almost wanting
to explode and then he pressed the book to his breast and he said I blessed this title I blessed
from my heart and I bless all the words with regard to my will and raising his right hand
with enchanting majesty he pronounced the words of blessing so there's Jesus the high priest and
having done this he disappeared so let's go to August the 31st 1926. Louisa said I was doing
my acts and my little rounds in the divine will according to my usual way I myself see how I can
do nothing but go around in it because it's my dear inheritance there's a little bit that's
important so don't forget if you don't do any rounds and you don't do anything you haven't visited
your inheritance and you haven't claimed it my way of understanding rounds which could be very
unorthodox is that you're actually signing your name to your inheritance so she said it's my dear
inheritance given to me by sweet Jesus in which there is so much to do and to learn and neither
my short life in the exile or the whole of eternity will be enough for me to fulfill all the offices
which are most extensive okay so notice that she understands she is going to be extremely busy in
heaven the other person that I know personally and can just say off the top of my head is Saint
Therese of Lesus who said she was going to work really hard in heaven until the end of history
so Louisa says here that this extensive inheritance whose boundaries cannot even be seen because
it's the kingdom of God and the more one goes around it the more new things one learns however
many things can be seen which cannot be understood that this is typical that's one Corinthians two
nine that you can't say everything you see it's not possible that there is no earthly language
for heavenly realities so let's go to the next paragraph where Jesus tells us that everything
about you and me and about redemption and about history and about the church and about everything
was decided as eternal in eternity in the bosom of the most blessed trinity so surprising me while
I was doing my acts in his adorable will my beloved Jesus told me my daughter look at how many things
we issued in creation with our fiat for the good of man's nature now this time the word nature is
used in a different way and this is what's so confusing about these writings is that whoever
translates it seems to use the same word in many different ways you're talking about man's body at
this particular point in other words our spirit incarnated in a body so it's for the needs of our
bodies everything that our will had established to issue nothing was missing in its fulfillment
now just as everything that we were to release in creation was established and nothing was absent
from our roll call from eternity everything was included so was everything that we were to issue
for the good of souls also established if you have your own book make sure you color that that
everything that was to bring you to the fullness of your calling and to bring you to the highest
place in heaven was established eternally everything so everything we were to issue for the good of
souls also established and in fact we did issue it and it was so great as to surpass by thousands
and thousands of times all the goods that can be seen in creation but both those that were to
serve the good of man's nature that's our bodily existence with those there were to serve the good
of his soul so you can see my interpretation is correct because there is the separation of the
needs of the body and the needs of soul everything remained deposited in our will so everything that
you need personally for body or soul has been established eternally so don't be afraid when they
want to prevent you from buying food the lord has his ways and means so but both those which were
to serve the good of man's body and those there were to serve the good of his soul everything remained
deposited in our will because we do not entrust our things to everyone or anyone knowing that our
will alone could preserve them for us and of course if human beings got their hands on and they would
interfere and change it as they do with everything even with human nature itself so the divine will
would preserve them whole and entire and beautiful just as they were delivered from the eternal
wound so more so since the divine will alone has the preserving and multiplying power which
while it gives it actually loses nothing and we've been told this over and over again the lord can
give absolutely everything we need but it is nothing to him because we have no idea how small we are
so in the next section he is telling us that each one of us is a heaven all by itself and he wants
to people it with a sun a moon and stars and all the rest of it and he wants to do something really
creatively wonderful in each one of us individually just as he created billions of galacties not just
billions of stars but billions of galacties now how many things there are in my will which i must give
to creatures but they have to come into its kingdom in order to receive them god has infinite capacity
but if we don't actually go there we can't receive them that's a bit like saying the supermarket is
full of food but if i actually don't go to a supermarket and do anything to get food then i
will be left hungry but it's nobody's fault except mine i just didn't go so if we don't actually come
into the divine will how can we receive all that he has for us just as the human being could never
partake of the goods of creation if it didn't want to live under the heavens and have a place on the
earth where the things created by me surrounded it like a crown in other words if you don't want
to live on the earth you won't cooperate with life in the same way if the soul does not want to come
to live under the heaven of my will you see as incarnated beings we're living under the heavens
that are above us and he's now saying that our soul needs to live under the heaven of his holy
will in the midst of the goods which our paternal goodness issued in order to make her happy to
establish her to enrich her she will never be able to partake of these goods they will be as though
foreign and unknown to her i've met you 11 20 there more so this is very important since each soul
would be a distinct heaven now two Corinthians 5 17 Paul says that each one of us is a new creation
each one of us is a creation because of the act of bringing us into being each of us is a new creation
because of redemption and now Jesus wants to raise that even higher and says that each one of us is
a new heaven now the word heaven actually means the canopy over our heads so that it's going to be
planets and stars and so on so since each soul would be a distinct heaven which our supreme will
would delight in adorning with a sun more radiant and with stars brighter than those that can be seen
in creation one more beautiful than the other so in other words God intended our interior to be
a whole creation in itself and no matter whether you have the same genetics as a twin that you're
born with you're still a completely different world for the Lord completely different everybody
is completely unique so he wants each one of us to be utterly radiant now as we go on in the higher
volumes he's going to be talking about peopling this interior heaven now for human nature there's
the sun over your head for everyone while for souls that's in the interior there is a sun for
each one of them there is an individual heaven there is an ever springing found there is a fire
that is never extinguished there is divine air to be breathed there's celestial food that makes the
soul grow in an admirable way in the likeness of the one who created her Luke 17 21 the kingdom
of God is within you the kingdom of God is that area that space that locus where God reigns and
where God can do his wonderful creative redemption redeeming and sanctifying work in us in other
words let the three fiats be expressed in us oh how many things my will keep prepared and established
to give to one who actually wants to live in the kingdom notice you have to want it and we're going
on to talk about that in i think the next message you have to actually want it because if we want
something we'll go and get it we'll turn head over heels to try and acquire it that aren't
thing but if you don't want it you'll do nothing about it so you have to actually really really
want it and we're a person arrives at in the divine will depends to a very large extent on how much
they actually want it and therefore how much they are prepared to pay as in terms of sacrificing
your own will and all the rest that the Lord wants from us so how many things that the Lord
has established to give us which have to actually want it so it does not want to entrust its goods
outside of its kingdoms you have to be in there in the kingdom because it knows that if they get
outside of its boundaries they will neither be appreciated nor understood there's your pearls
before swine you can't do that and you know yourself trying to talk this language to somebody
who's not in the divine will they haven't a clue what you're saying more so since the divine will
alone knows how to preserve and keep its goods alive and only one who lives in the divine will
is capable of number one understanding the celestial language that's number one he says only one who
lives in it now he doesn't say one who just does a few acts every now and then he doesn't say that
and number two only one who lives in the divine will is capable of receiving its gifts okay
and number three only one who is living in the divine will is capable of looking and understanding
and appreciating its beauty and number four only one living in the divine will is capable of forming
one single life with the divine will take those four things and write them out separately for
yourself and it'll make huge sense on the other hand one who doesn't want to live in the divine
will in its kingdom is incapable of understanding its goods her tongue will not be able to speak
or adapt itself to the language of the kingdom nor will she be able to look at its beauties on
the contrary she will remain blind because of the intense light that is in the divine will
so there's your one Corinthians two verses 14 to 15 again the one who will not enter into a spiritual
relationship with the Lord remains blind they don't actually say now in the next paragraph
what we have is the power of the human will to destroy everything absolutely everything that
God has planned for us see then for how long have all the goods that we must give the children of
the supreme fear have been issued from our paternal womb everything has been prepared since the time
of creation nor will we withdraw because of the delay we will keep waiting now he has said that
many times another place he has said that the human generations won't finish until he gets his
purpose no sooner than the creature places her will at the footstool of hours to let it dominate
will we open the doors for her now there's something very specific said there and we need to do this
I do it every single night to make sure he hears me that I place my will in the hands and in the
immaculate heart of our blessed mother and that she is to place it at the footstool of the Lord
and she's to do it at every nano second of my life up to and including my last breath
she's authorized to do it for me she has my permission she has my permission to take this
will and hold on to it that is absolutely essential and I just need to point out as essential
not as a nice few words that you will say but that's something you're actually doing
and that if you hand over your will like that that you are authorizing our blessed mother to
actually deal with it and therefore she has rights it's terribly important for us to understand that
this is not a case of just saying nice words our nice prayers that we're actually handing over
our will okay very important no sooner than the creature places her will at the footstool of hours
to allow the divine will to dominate will we open the doors for her
you see the condition we will open the doors to let her enter because it was the human will that
closed the doors that's in Genesis chapter three two hours and open the doors to all misery okay
and to all weakness and passions and so on so it was not her memory or her intelligence
that placed themselves against the creator even though they concurred it was her will
so we have to understand that sin is in the will and we have to understand that our giving of
ourselves to God is in the will it has nothing to do with feelings it's nothing to do with you
feeling a wonderful close relationship with God or anything else I can hand over a gift to you
with no feelings but I'm still handing it to you and we hand over our will regardless of whether
you feel anything or you don't feel it if we use feelings as they measure or the thermometer
is all over feelings are like the weather forecast so it was the human will that had
the first act and broke all the bonds all the relationships with the will so holy more so since
all good and we've been talking about the nature of good and all evil is enclosed in the human
will that needs to be underlined in many colors all good and all evil is enclosed in the human
will the regime the dominion is its own and so once the will has failed and good everything fails
loses the order decays from its origin and becomes ugly vip vip it's in the will it doesn't matter
how you feel you could feel very upset about something and absolutely forgive somebody in your will
doesn't matter how upset you feel about what they're doing to you and since it was the human will
that placed itself against mine causing all goods to fail man this is why I want his will because he
wants us to recover and in exchange I want to give him mine now my reaction to that is a latin one
oh admirabile comertium what a marvelous exchange oh admirabile comertium imagine I give this silly
human will that only causes me trouble to him and he gives me a divine will in its place there's
absolutely no way you can make any comparison no way at all so I want to give him mine to give it
back to him so that I can give back to him all the goods that have failed him therefore my daughter
be attentive never give life to your will if you want mine to reign so that's why I've been saying
ever since I began classes in the divine will that on a daily basis we have to be saying to that
not my will but thine be done not my will but thine be one okay in the next paragraph he goes on
to tell us that the human will paralyzes the soul so that it can do nothing and all you have to do
is look out the window at society all around us and you can see them paralyzed in everything
it's frightening this frightening after this Jesus kept silent remaining all afflicted because of the
great evil produced in souls by the human will to the point of disfiguring his beautiful image
that image given in Genesis 1 27 and 2 7 infused in them in creating them and sighing he added my
daughter the human will paralyzes the life of my will in the soul now paralysis is a terrible thing
because without my will the divine life does not circulate in the soul which more than pure blood
preserves her motion her vigor her perfect use of her mental faculties in such a way as to make
her grow healthy and holy so that we may recognize our likeness in her now here you've got a description
of divine health coming to a person who is in the divine will in other words the complete
integration of that person actually takes place oh how many souls are paralyzed without my will
he said what a pitiful scene to see the human generations almost all paralyzed in the soul
and this is a very good description of society today therefore they are irrational they're blind
to seeing good they are deaf for listening to the truth they're mute in teaching it they are in
art for holy works they're immobile in walking on the path to heaven because the human will
preventing the circulation of my will forms the general paralysis in the souls of creatures so I
want to give you Isaiah 6 9 a holy man who had a vision of God in the temple and suddenly he said
what a wretched man I am he said I'm like the rest of them and he said my mouth and as soon as he
acknowledged his mouth because we commit so many sins with our mouth and we're not even aware of it
his mouth was cleansed I want to give you Matthew 13 verses 14 and 15 as well it's the same he said
for the human body the majority of illnesses especially things like paralysis are caused by a lack of
blood circulation wouldn't you love the doctors to know if the blood circulates well the human
being is robust and strong he feels no disquiet but if some irregularity begins in the blood circulation
in dispositions weaknesses and consumption begin I think consumption is what we used to call tv
and if the circulation becomes quite irregular he becomes paralyzed because that blood which
does not circulate and does not flow rapidly in his veins forms the grave evils of the human body
what would creatures not do if they knew there was a remedy for the regularity of blood circulation
who knows where they would travel to and what trouble they would go to in order to get a cure
and yet there is the great remedy of my will to avoid any evil of the soul so as not to become
paralyzed in good but to grow strong and robust in sanctity I love those two words to grow strong
and robust in holiness that's a very very wonderful word now that's drinks and that robustness
has to do with the fact that the soul is healed and that it is becoming stronger and stronger in virtue
and in grace and in likeness to the lord and therefore the lord can do more and more and more
with this person strong and robust in sanctity but who takes it who takes the divine will and still
it's a remedy given out for free nor do they have to wander around in order to get it rather it's
always ready to give itself and to constitute itself as the regular life of the creature and
what's sorrow my daughter what sorrow what sorrow now it's very close to the time do you want me
to start another one oh yes please okay let's go on to september the third 1926 and this is extremely
important as well he's just been telling us the extraordinary thing that happens when we enter
into the divine will and grow robust and strong now he's going to tell us that everything depends
on your desire if you don't really want it you're going to do nothing if you don't really want to
grow in holiness you're not going to pay the price and so we have to ask how much of god do we really
want this it's a very important one to finish with tonight louisa said i was feeling all identified
with my sweet Jesus and i was praying him from the heart to watch over my poor soul so that nothing
might enter into it which was not his will now while i was doing this my dear good my sweet life
moved in my interior and said my daughter the desire for a good this is extremely important
the desire for knowing that good purges the soul and disposes her intelligence to understand it
now notice what helps the intelligence it's not your IQ it's not your level of education it's your
desire to know god that takes the excuse away from us all it's the desire for a good the desire
for knowing it it purges the soul and it disposes her intelligence to understand it her memory to
remember it her will feels the appetite for it being wet to make of it its food and life
and the desire moves god to give her that good and to make it known in other words if you actually
want it the lord will give it to you but if you only want a tiny bit that's all you will get
saint the rays of this you says you will receive from god exactly how much you have confidence to
receive from him if you want everything that's fine so the desire for a good for knowing it is
like appetite for food where there is appetite one feels the taste eats with pleasure remains
satisfied and content with having taken the food and is left with the desire to enjoy it again
on the other hand if there's no appetite the same food which is enjoyed so eagerly by one person
causes nausea and disgust to someone else who has no appetite and he may reach the point of
suffering because of it that is the way desire works for the soul it's like appetite and in seeing
that the desire for my things is her delight to the point of making them her food and life
I abound I abound so much in giving that I never tire of giving now notice he opens the floodgates
of generosity towards us if we are interested if we actually want it on the other hand for one who
doesn't desire them because the appetite is missing one feels nozier for my things and that gospel
saying is repeated it will be given to one who has while one who does not desire my goods my truths
and my celestial things will be deprived of the little that he has we have seen whole societies
lose faith today haven't we they've lost the little faith they had because they lost their desire
for God this is a just penalty for one who does not desire and has no appetite for and wants to
know nothing about the things that belong to me in other words why would the Lord leave a treasure
in your hands when you're not even interested and if he has any little thing at all it's right that
it be taken away from him and be given to those who possess much do you remember the man with the 10
talents and the man with one talent Matthew 1312 is the first saying okay now in the next paragraph
he talks about the wonderful liberality with which he wants to give to us everything depends on us
being open wanting it and ready to receive that's all we don't have to be special then after this
i was thinking about and identifying with the holy divine will and finding myself in its immense
light that's one timothy six sixteen god dwells in unapproachable light i felt its divine rays
penetrating so deep now notice how badly she wants the lord into me as to transform me into that very
light two Corinthians three eighteen you are transformed into the one whom you contemplate and Jesus
coming out of my interior told me my daughter how beautiful how penetrating how communicative how
transforming is the light of my will now notice the word transforming is used correct there because
you're being transformed into light whereas the word was used wrongly earlier it was deformed
okay it is more than the sun which pounding on the earth gives with liberality the effect says
light contains nor does it wait to be asked but spontaneously as its light fills the surface of
the earth it gives what it has to everything it encounters now this is the liberality of god
it's for everybody it's for everything he gives and gives and gives all he wants is to have someone
to give to so he gives the example of the sun there it gives sweetness and taste to the fruit
color and fragrance to the flower development of the plants and to all things it gives its effects
and goods it contains and he makes no exception with anybody this is where we have to become like
god and have love without boundaries and prayer without boundaries that it's for everybody in all
generations it's enough that the light touches them penetrates them and warms them for it to
accomplish its work if you're really worried about somebody you could after fusing in the divine
will just simply say lord send forth your light and renew that person and renew everybody to the
ends of the earth send forth your light because it says it's enough that the light actually just
touches them it will do its transforming work so my will is more than the sun you're expecting this
as long as the soul exposes herself to its vivifying rays that's very important and she
banishes the darkness in the night for human will you see there's no point in doing one unless you
do the other you must banish the darkness of the human will its light rises and invests the soul
penetrating into our inmost fibers the lord will go as far as you are open to dispel from her the
shadows and the atoms of the human will now the atoms are the tiny little bits of leftovers you
think you've given the human will and you notice these little shadows and atoms and you find that
in reading these volumes that the lord often says to louisa that is tidying up something that she's
doing so as its light pounds on the soul and she receives it the divine will communicate all the
effects it contains that's all of the divine qualities because coming out of the supreme being
my will contains all the qualities of the divine nature and that's what's poured into us so in
investing her it communicates the goodness the love the power the firmness that is fortitude
the mercy at all the divine qualities but not in a superficial way in a real way and therefore we
have a way of actually testing how we're doing in the divine will because we should be growing in all
of these areas in a real way such as to transmute all of its qualities into the human person so much
so that the soul will feel within herself as her own the nature at all the qualities of true goodness
power sweetness and mercy look at the sweetness that is in the face of all trouble remember reading
the hours of the passion louisa so frequently says about the sweetness of jesus to the men who
are torturing him and so with all the rest of the supreme qualities my will alone has this power to
convert its virtues into one's nature that is the transformation that we become more and more like
the one who made us but only for one who abandons herself pray to its light that means you have to
really give the will and to its heat and keeps the tenuous night of her own will away from her
so the conditions are not difficult to understand because the human will is the true and perfect
night of the human soul so we have a lot there to think about and i think it's very rich so
thank you for joining us god bless